[Musique]
bienvenue au you go c'est le magnifique
territoire dans le grand nord canadien
où j'ai grandi
malheureusement là bas comme dans tous
les écosystèmes de la planète
parfois il ya des accidents des
déversements pétroliers comme celui là
laissent des marques longtemps après le
déversement initiale bien s'ouvre dans
le seul il ya des micro organismes qui
peuvent travailler pour dégrader les
hydrocarbures pétroliers
mais cette atténuation naturel est
longue puis l'un des climats froids
comment il compte c'est très long j'ai
pris conscience de ça lorsque je
travaille pour le ministère de
l'environnement
notre rôle était de se rendre sur des
sites en région éloignée comme celui là
parfois et de retirer des baril pétrole
ou des sols contaminés par contre c'est
loin et on s'en donne hélicoptère un
camion qui ont brûlé une quantité
incroyable de pétrole pour sortir du
pétrole du front des régions éloignées
ça me semblait un peu contre intuitif
par contre je crois qu'on est tous
d'accord qu'on peut pas laisser ça là
alors on les retire
et puis qu'est ce qu'il en advient la
méthode traditionnelle c'est de la même
plate forme de traitement on ajoute
jusqu'à utilisant inorganiques jo de
pékin puis embrassent l'idée c'est de
stimuler les micro organismes dans le
sol avec un apport de nutriments pour
que puisse se dégrader le carbone dans
le pétrole j'aimerais juste souligner
dans des régions tempérées comme le sud
du québec 6 a fait ses preuves
ça fonctionne dans nord poteau jours des
fois c'est efficace mais des fois ça des
résultats mitigés et c'est pas efficace
du tout en fait ça a des effets
inhibiteurs et c'est moins efficace que
si on avait laissé les microbes faire
leur travail
une méthode d'accélérer ce processus là
dans north brasser les sols si au québec
c'est pas permis mais là bas si vous
voulez vous pouvez les bras c'est à tous
les jours ces différents impacts devant
on brûle encore du pétrole pour faire
rouler la machinerie et puis ma une
certaine relativisation du sol vers
l'atmosphère tempo idéal autre chose qui
à mon avis n'est pas idéal
utilisation des fertilisants
inorganiques c'est que souvent ils
viennent de très loin c'est vrai qu'un
bouc ou transport pour les amener en or
j'attends quand même des processus
énergivores pour les synthétiser parfois
mais ils proviennent de sources
et puis sable comme le phosphore et
finalement si on essaie d'être traités
sur le site même sont au pied de la
montagne comme on a vu tantôt dans les
chercheurs ont trouvé que l'apport de
fertilisants inorganiques pu stimuler la
croissance de plantes envahissantes au
lieu des plaies des espèces de plantes
native ces espèces et effet leur sont
visibles jusqu'à 15 ans dans le futur
donc c'est énorme comme impact alors
bref j'étais pas satisfaite tout à fait
du statu quo mais j'avais pas de
solution quand je me suis mis en quête
de solutions et 7,4 commence au coeur la
bête de mode d'extraction de pétrole
conventionnel on trouve un gisement on
pompe à la surface le gisement lui son
histoire date à 210 millions d'années
prenons par exemple une forêt en milieu
humide s est enfoui on ajoute des
conditions particulières de la pression
des millions d'années et adore on a du
pétrole
elle saura si vous vous demandez
peut-être vrai mais les plantes les
champignons les bactéries quel rôle on l
a joué aujourd'hui pour cette gestion la
voici la beauté de la nature
prenons un arbre sur la voie verte une
blessure poussins champions qu'annoncé
ces coriaces un arbre et s'il y en a
parmi vous qui ont déjà essayé de
marcher une bûche ces coriaces c'est dur
une bûche spectacle at il pourtant le
champignon lui est en train de s'en
nourrir dollar c'est notamment parce que
l'habileté de dégrader la ligne n
la ligne n c'est un polymère végétal
récalcitrants qui donne à résister aux
espèces ligneuses comme les arbres les
arbustes massicois salaire de plus près
si on plonge dans le fond du baril de
pétrole
voici de quoi la structure moléculaire à
l'art de quelques-unes
multiples molécules qui le composent
peut voir que certaines similitudes
notamment les tisanes ou de benzène qui
font partie de certains polluants
récalcitrants dans les composés pétrole
comme les pères à l'échappée et d'autres
acteurs est visible aussi qui vivent
sous le sol les plantes les arbres
investissent une grande quantité de
ressources notamment les sucres la
photosynthèse pour stimuler la
croissance des micro-organismes dans le
sol ces bactéries leurs gamins d'entre
elles qui peut aussi manger des chaînes
de carbone qui sont similaires jamais
carbone dans le pétrole donc simplifié
impulsive et c'est pour vous donner une
idée du rôle que ces trois grandes
composantes peuvent avoir à jouer
maintenant notre arbre à jouer dans la
dégradation des hydrocarbures pétroliers
et des problèmes de contenir notre arme
lui vip en isolation avec son champignon
et vit dans une forêt via plusieurs
espèces d'arbres des milliards de
bactéries sous le sol et plusieurs
espèces de champignons qui peuvent lier
à l'aide de leurs mycélium diverses
espèces de plantes et même des bactéries
qui sort le long du flair des ces
filaments de mycélium là ces trois
grandes composantes évolué ensemble dans
des écosystèmes complexes
depuis des millions d'années dans la
nature y avait pas de déchets évolué
ensemble un coup oui de compétition
combat vie la loi de la jungle mais
surtout à coups de collaboration tout
dans le système et manger réincorporer
recyclé si on venait à notre pétrole
naissances espérances cette relation
tripartite kouyou qu'on ne voulu
l'appliquer pour le nettoyage de sols
contaminés sur deux sites en particulier
près de la ville de whitehorse le
premier c était contaminée au diesel on
a mis nos trois composantes sous cette
forme
premièrement le compost qui étonna part
de nutriments un apport de
micro-organismes bénéfique qui
améliorent la texture du sol qui est un
peu une plateforme de soutien pour les
plantes les champignons ou si ensuite on
a ajouté le pleurote qui est un incident
peu de champignons carrie blanche qui
est déjà reconnu pour ses habiletés à
dégrader certains composés pétroliers à
base de ben 10
notamment finalement côté plantes on a
mis un sol
c'est l'ex planifolia c'est son petit
nom latin cette plante là est connu dans
nord comme étant une des survivantes
lorsque des déversements pétroliers ex
dentelle en milieu naturel
notre deuxième site c'est un défi de
taille
c'est en fait une fausse avait luz et
qu'on a placé sur des anciens stériles
miniers d'une mine de cuivre puis ça a
été de rester touchés un touché pendant
environ 40 ans on peut voir sa femme un
petit mot mordor n'y a pas grand chose
qui pose là dessus c'est un 7-1
contamination mixte
donc il ya des composés chlorés des
métaux et beaucoup d'hydrocarbures
pétroliers jusqu'à 20% de la masse du
sol la première chose qu'on a mis effet
des plantes
on était avec deux la même qu'au premier
site sélestat l'unifolié et une deuxième
salle ex alex prentice parce que
d'autres chercheurs avaient trouvé qui
fait recruter dans saison dressler des
micro organismes qui avaient l'habilité
des grades et des composés chlorés
deuxièmement on me traite versicolor un
champignon du titre qui arrive blanche
également mais qui connu comme étant
encore plus agressif que le pleurote et
finalement du compost pour les mêmes
raisons qu au premier set je voudrais
prendre un moment pour souligner qu'on a
vraiment voulu opérer dans un mode
d'économie circulaire
alors le compost on est usé un compost à
partir de résidus table des résidents de
la ville de whitehorse nos espèces de
plantes et de champignons et des espèces
natives présente dans la région on ne
mène qu'à une aux boutures de saules
tout près de la ville et puis à mon
excuse et on voulait vraiment valoriser
les matières locales notamment avec les
copeaux de bois pour le traitement de
champignons qui étaient issus des
équipes d'entretien le long des routes
de la ville alors comment est-ce qu'on a
procédé pour mettre tous vos onglets
ensemble au premier set
on est usé des bacs on a mis différents
composants combinaison de nos trois
composantes biologiques
on a gardé un bac avec rien c'était
notre contrôle pour représenter
l'atténuation naturel
et finalement du fertilisant organique
pour comparer la méthode industrielle
habituel à notre méthode écosystémiques
qu'est ce que ça a donné lorsque je suis
arrivé sur le terrain j'ai vu ça à la
fin du premier et et j'étais très
heureuse de voir nos bacs qui était
couvert de grosses fructification
pleurotes ça mais ça me confirmer que
notre champignons étaient bien vivants
dans notre système également dans ce
traitement en particulier on observer la
plus grande baisse d'hydrocarbures
prêterai pétrolier donc une baisse de
75% du diesel après trois ans c'est le
compost qui remporté par conte avec une
baisse de 95% pour la fosse habits usés
et bien on a travaillé en cellule on
avait tous cellule avec environ un mètre
cube chacune dans six de ces cellules
on a mis nos trois composantes
biologiques dans l'essai autres rien
c'est un autre contrôle pour
l'atténuation naturel après cinq ans
voici les premiers résultats visibles
voici les premiers résultats facilement
visible c'est au niveau de l'apparence
notre contrôle et aujourd'hui le noir
foncé il centrait fort tandis que notre
méthode est que ce n'est que donner un
espèce de seul qui ressemble un terreau
mais attention à l'époque tout planter
vos carottes les analyses ne révèlent
qu'il ya une baisse de 70% de tous les
hydrocarbures pétroliers dans ce
traitement là ceci inclut les grosses
fraction lourde entre 50 carbone qui
sont visqueuse qui est absolument
difficile à se débarrasser le contrôle
quant à lui on a vu une baisse de 20%
les composés chlorés était parti à
l'intérieur de la première année mais
les métaux les métaux ce sont des
éléments du tableau périodique
donc on peut pas les dégradés par contre
on peut les extraire les accumuler ce
qu'on a voulu faire avec les plantes
alors l'été passé on ne guérit tous les
sols sur le site et c'est en asie essayé
actuellement on analyse on va voir si ce
sont des bonnes espèces profiter aux
accumulations
maintenant on voit que le taux de
contamination a baissé mais on se pose
la question est ce que le cop théo
restant de d'hydrocarbures pétrolier de
maisdon et elle sait qu'elle est pour
répondre à ça on augmentait 150 g de
seigle dans chacun des traitements en
laboratoire on a vu que 90% des graines
germées dans notre traitement
écosystémiques tandis que 60% germé dans
le contrôle qu'ils étaient
significativement plus petit ce
résultat-là à son homologue sur le
terrain pendant les cinq ans que la
l'expérience a duré et bien d'autres
prophètes désherbage qu'on peut voir que
le traitement écosystémiques vraiment
beaucoup plus de végétation nos sols
sont cachés quelque part là non le
champignon qu'on a vu le très net
versicolor n'ont malheureusement pas
survécu
par contre depuis les trois dernières
années on a un petit champignon de la
famille des satires est menacée qui
apparaît agen qui apparaît mais pas dans
nos bacs contrôle alors voilà nos
résultats démontrent qu en s'inspirant
de la nature
on est dix ans les matières locales
résiduelles en utilisant des espèces
natives de l'endroit c'est possible de
développer des modes de traitement des
sols en or qui sont très efficaces
par contre j'aimerais vraiment souligner
qu' on développe pas une méthode au nord
du 60e parallèle méthode miracle on peut
ensuite transposé partout sur la planète
de façon exacte
ça marche ça fonctionne malheureusement
pas comme ça mais ce qui se trouve
partout sur la planète c'est cette
relation tripartite est également
partout sur la planète via des matières
et déchets qui sont en fait des
ressources qui n'attendent qu'à être
valorisée puis parlant des chutes en
tout j'ai souligné que dans la nature
j'aime pas de déchets alors j'aimerais
vous inviter un instant fermer les yeux
et visualiser votre sac de poubelle
combien de sacs de poubelle qui quitte
votre maison personnelle votre travail
si vous en faites un peu l'inventaire
quelles proportions sont en fait des
ressources des pelures d'orange qui
pourraient du compost du marc de café
pour faire pousser des champignons
des plastiques qui pour être recyclés ou
transformés en combustible des espèces
d' amalgame bizarre de plastique métal
ça serait juste pour exister devrait
fabriquer pour être démontables bref je
dis pas ça pour vous culpabiliser mais
simplement pour vous inviter à porter un
oeil un peu plus critique sur toutes les
ressources autour de vous qui
n'attendent qu'à être valorisés pour
partir du sol par tourner vraies
structures sociales filtrer l'eau
extérieur mais surtout surtout pour
léguer une planète un peu plus en santé
à vos petit petit petit enfant merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]